recording right okay um let's start um
welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
admit and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that
we can address them in q and a session
at the end second today's gdps seminar
is open to external audiences therefore
no classified discussion is allowed
so please watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host ashish
chatham
hat
who is a peace student at rice
university he did his bachelor's uh from
the department of mechanical engineering
at
indian institute of technology
patna
where he worked primarily in
optimization and computational geometry
for fluid interface modeling
he got his masters from the university
of texas el paso from the computational
science program
where his research was focused on high
performance computing
since then she has been a phd student at
vice university in the department of
mechanical engineering
where he works at the intersection of
theoretical deep learning dynamical
systems and turbulence modeling for
broad applications in forecasting
atmospheric dynamics and extreme weather
during his phd
he has spent a year and a half at
lawrence berkeley national lab
as a research intern affiliate working
in different areas of geometric and
generative deep learning for
stochastic emulation of all
system models
today i just
will give a talk with the title of
deep learning meets data assimilation
on physically consistent architectures
and hybrid
sample kalman filters
for weather forecasting
please expect a wonderful talk and enjoy
it
now without further ado
let me press the button to assist by
asking one random question as usual
today's random question is
what is your favorite things to do other
than research
so the maximum amount of time i spend
outside research is with a small group
of people where we have a small musical
band so i spent a lot of time in music
so yeah apart from that i think it's
been more or less phd
nice do you play any instrument yeah i i
play a percussion instrument called the
cajon
i never heard of it
yeah it's it's a version of a drum where
your neighbors don't get very angry at
you so that's okay
all right sounds good okay the stacy
yours is yours ashish thank you
thank you so much thank you so much for
the introduction
okay so my name is ashish i'll be
talking today about uh some aspects of
putting deep learning and data
simulation together with physically
consistent architectures and the kind of
data estimation algorithms that i talk
about today are sequential ones and i'll
introduce them and how it works and it'd
be based on ensemble calming filters and
all this is aimed towards applications
uh in weather and climate modeling how
to improve current weather and climate
models uh and so on
but in doing so we're going to look at a
hierarchy of complexity in terms of
systems and how to
how to develop algorithms in for example
say a simpler system and then generalize
it to more complex systems
so uh before i start i want to uh give
out uh my my sincere thanks to all my
mentors and collaborators uh a
significant portion of this work was
done at lawrence working national lab
where i spent some time uh most of it uh
was done with my advisor pedram
hassanzadeh um uh and my colleague
ibrahim uh
at rice and uh our collaborator at
currently was at lmd in paris aviator
bach
okay so the motivation behind most of
the work that we do in our lab and and
what i worked on is our weather and
climate system and and the challenge
that with that weather and climate
systems have is that it's a multi-scale
chaotic dynamical system
and and the process the physical
processes uh that are involved in inner
weather system
ranges from for example micrometers to
tens and thousands of kilometers in
space as well as seconds or minutes to
maybe multiple years in terms of time so
it's it's a multi-scale system and there
is really no scale separation most of
the physical processes that are
happening inside the weather system for
example
uh in in in the west system you would
see very large scale very large scale
for example the large scale circulation
or the weather maps that we see in our
new station to synoptic scale patterns
for example thunderstorms and tornadoes
to very small scale uh small scale
processes for example gravity waves
which in today's state-of-the-art
climate models
or many of the climate models today are
actually under-resolved or not resolved
at all and parameterized
so the difficulty the challenge here in
in writing climate model for example or
or uh
or really resolving uh uh the the flow
around uh from the entire earth is that
you have to resolve uh both your space
and time
into into a very large number of grid
points and a very large number of
waypoints to account for the very small
scale processes as well if you really
wanted to resolve all the physical
processes ranging from the micrometers
to the kilometers right so you could
typically think of the system as having
a large scale flow x and and and a
smaller of a scale flow y and then there
is some poorly understood variables
uh maybe maybe you could think that
gravity waves is one of those fully
understood variables that that that
maybe we could ignore for the time being
although they are actually parameterized
in climate models uh but if you think of
it that way then then ideally what
climate models would do that is that
they would really resolve the large
scale flow that is they will actually go
and integrate the uh
the equations of the large scale
dynamics numerically
and they would somehow approximately
account for the effect that the small
scale processes would have on the large
scale variables right and this process
is called parameterization for example
convection is parameterized in in many
other climate models uh clouds for
example are very small-scale processes
so they they cannot really be resolved
in in many of the climate models so they
have to be parameterized while more and
more eastern climate models actually do
have uh cloud-resolving components as
well and i'll talk about it in a little
bit
but the idea is you can't really afford
to resolve all the processes that's not
computationally tractable so what you do
is resolve some of the results of the
large scale processes and then you
really account for the effects of the
small case small scale processes on the
large scale ins in form of some
approximation either these are
semi-empirical approximations driven by
physics or more recently there's been a
certain interest for having data-driven
approximations where you can really
learn from data
so if you think about today's challenges
in terms of data driven modeling for
improving weather and climate models
then we could maybe divide it and this
is really my perspective of it you could
really divide into three major category
of problems
the first one being can you account for
these unresolved physical processes in a
data-driven manner so uh here what
you're seeing is that uh there is when
you when you when you divide the earth
into large larger grades tractable
bridge 100 kilometers or so then you're
not accounting for the dynamics of the
physical processes that are within that
hundred kilometers right the small scale
processes
and that and so if you really want to
solve the governing equations you have
to account for the forcing that those
small scale processes would give on on
the large scale on the scale flow
and and so far in climate models you
have this semi-empirical function f
which is which is derived from physics
and and a bit of empirics as well and
you really account for how these small
scale processes may may vary as a
function of the large scale flow
right so so really the idea is uh
have a static function
uh that is that is purely a function of
the large scale variables but accounts
for
the accounts for the effects that it
would have that the small scale
processes would have for the large scale
flow
or what one can do is that if you could
afford high resolution simulations for
example say locally or if you have
observations
which are
high resolution enough
then you can learn the effects you can
learn the tendency of these small square
processes y as a function of x by using
some sort of a data driven model and and
i call this a neural network could be a
kind of neural network could be
something else as well but but you don't
have an a purely structure as to how y
varies as a function of x but you could
really just fit a very over
parameterized model and see and you see
whether you get a good representation of
why or not and these approaches are
called data-driven approaches and
they're called ddp
but of course you see there's a problem
here is that you really you're really
saying that y is in quasi-equilibrium
with x that that is
y
varies purely as a function of x it does
not it does not vary as a function for
for example of its memory of its memory
so it is not dependent on how y varies
in the previous time steps but we know
that is the fact because y is also a
dynamical
the the evolution of y is also common by
a dynamical system so y should be
non-markovian in nature
and and that approach is called super
parameterization and this actually does
exist in many of the climate quantities
although they're not i guess
uh operational ones for example e3 sm is
a super parameterized model from the aoe
uh from n car it used to be um
sp cam which was a super parameterized
cam model
and the idea behind super
parameterization was that okay i will
resolve the large scale variables on a
on a low resolution grid
but inside each of these grid cells
as you see inside each of these grid
cells
i will i will dyna i will numerically
solve the equations governing the small
scale processes y but maybe not the
exact equations maybe some approximation
of that something that is more tractable
so
in doing so what you do what what you
what you ensure is that you don't assume
that y is in quasi-equilibrium with x
you actually solve uh
the the time dependent y equations to
some extent and a data driven version of
that
these are the things that we had worked
on was that you
you if you if you were to afford high
resolution simulations or had
observations then you try to fit a in a
stateful neural network like for example
a record in neural network as a function
of both the large scale variables
and the small scale variables of the
previous time step
now as you know as you understand these
are not purely data driven models you
need to then couple these equations back
into your large scale numerical solver
and then we'll solve it in a tightly
coupled fashion
so this is one aspect of what
data-driven data-driven modeling in
climate and weather looks like today
of course
there's another uh approach to doing
this is that we really are often just
interested in the large scale
variability for example we're interested
in the large scale circulation
not necessarily about
we don't not
necessarily want to probe into the small
scale process as long as we are
correctly accounting for them so we
could have a fully data-driven model
that just learned from the large-scale
variables so it can it can just look at
the time history
one can just look at the time history of
the large-scale variable and evolve it
with a neural network
while this is obviously a much more
challenging problem because you're not
really accounting for y but just
assuming that somehow the information of
y is independent in x this has been a a
an area of recent interest from from
multiple different groups including ours
work relab and university of washington
well dale duran and jonathan wayne have
shown some really amazing results
of what you could achieve by by training
a complicated enough neural network on
observational data and and how you can
forecast you can actually come very
close to our operational forecasting
stand where operation forecasting stands
today
so the third aspect of it is improving
data simulation and data assimilation
i'll talk about it in more details is
that it's a it's a process by which you
integrate observational data so you take
observations which come in as noisy and
sparse data and you integrate into your
dynamical model uh in such a way that
you have a better representation a
better estimate of yours of the state of
the system with which you can start
forecasting and today i'll focus on the
the the second the the second and the
third point here i look at climate
models that look like this ddwp stands
for data-driven weather weather
prediction so this is not a coupled
numerical
uh deep learning scheme it's a purely
data driven scheme where you have
where you're trying to predict the large
scale variable directly with the health
data-driven model and then i look at how
i can use deep learning to improve data
simulation to some extent or at least
enhance computations involved in data
simulation how these two can be tightly
coupled together for forecasting
applications i will not focus on any of
the work uh related to ddp or ddsp
so to look at the to look at the kind of
developments that we did we will look at
a hierarchy of systems not directly go
to the most complex climate model level
but we'll first look at a two-layer
quasi-juice traffic flow and develop a
hybrid deep learning based uh
data simulation scheme look at how we
can tractably generate large number of
ensembles repetitions and the challenges
and opportunities there and then we are
going to look at re-analysis or
observations so go to the most complex
climate so the re-analysis is not
completely observations so it is it has
a greater simulation component to it as
well but is the closest to observations
that we can get so we're going to look
at how we can facilitate predictions by
training on actual observational data
and how we can couple da schemes to a
ddwp model at that
at this uh hierarchy of complexity as
well so obviously
getting data
from reanalysis would involve running a
full nwp
so
the computational cost is obviously much
higher the complexity of this data is
much higher than the complexity of these
data as well so this is more or less a
chart uh really development would
involve making this line much more dense
having more many more systems making
sure to generalize across these systems
but i'll look at these two things today
so a little bit about data assimilation
so data explanation is used in
engineering and the earth sciences uh
in both engineering and earth sciences
and in fact it's an indispensable
process in weather forecasting
and and the way it works or the way it
looks like is this suppose you have a
system and you have a dynamical model of
your system with which you want to
forecast it so ideally you start with an
initial condition which may not be
accurate it could be noisy it could be
sparse you may have interpolated onto a
grid so that it can facilitate the
resolution of your dynamical model
and you start forecasting with your
model now more often than not this model
of your system especially if the system
is complex will not have all the
relevant physics it will have some
missing component or it would have some
parameterizations which are not accurate
so your model trajectory is going to
deviate from the true trajectory of your
system
right and and from from time and again
you will get observations from your
systems which are division given in red
and the idea of data simulation is that
you take the model forecast you take the
observation at that time if it's
available
and then you combine these two
information to come up with an estimate
of your state which may be a more
faithful and a true representation of
the state of your system at that point
of time and in a sequential data
estimation algorithm for example enkf
that i'll talk about ensemble kelvin
filter as you have more and more
observations you are going to converge
to a more correct uh or a true
representation of your state as you keep
on
updating an ensemble typing filter so as
you move on and you get more and more
observations your estimated state is
going to be more closer to the true
trajectory as compared to your model
state
or as compared to an observation which
is actually going to be very noisy so
observations come in as very noisy as
fast data uh
you have to be able to assimilate them
before it can be used to be
useful anyway
and once you have this estimate of your
state you can start forecasting by
treating this as the initial condition
as compared to an observation on a model
forecast so use this initial condition
which is a better representation of the
state you could get better forecast
accuracies with your dynamic model even
though it might have missing physics
so
in order to propose the algorithm that
we want to talk about and we're going to
propose a hybrid ensemble kalman filter
which has a deep learning component to
it the system that that we will consider
is a two-layer quality geos traffic flow
a two-layer quasi-geostrophic flow
and um in this system this is a very
simple climate model very simple
two-layer climate model it's used as a
canonical like a textbook example to
start off with new algorithms uh it has
two two layers so it has two states the
states are going to be the stream
function at the upper and the lower
level what you're showing in the view
what i'm showing on the video is the
shading which is given by which is the
velocity and then the open contours of
the stream function this is a good
representation this is simple but a
great representation of the mid-latitude
dynamics of the earth
so
it's not a full climate model but it
it's not even close to a full climate
model where it's a good place to start
so it's a fully turbulent flow so it is
all complexities that you would see in
atmospheric dynamics in terms of the
nature of turbulence that exists in
concrete animals
so let's look at what a regular data
assimilation with ensemble kelvin filter
would look like in a system like this so
you start with an initial condition okay
of your of the state of your system and
then you perturb this initial condition
to generate an ensemble and you put up
with typically maybe using gaussian
randomize
and then you have a bunch of ensemble
members right and each ensemble member
is indexed by j over here
so what you do then is that you use a
numerical model of of your qg flow for
example in the system and you integrate
each of these ensemble members
until for example say 200 delta t and
why did i choose 200 delta t here
because in this system that's equivalent
to one day one earth day
and suppose assume that in this system
you have observations coming in every
day albeit they commit come in as as as
noisy observations not not not perfect
ones
so the first thing that you would do a
while while implementing your ensemble
calvin filter is that you would first
compute this background covariance
matrix which is the expectation of this
quantity
and if you look carefully this quantity
is dependent on all the ensemble members
that you have integrated for 200 delta t
once you compute this background
covariance you're going to you get a
kelvin gain
which is uh that the carbon gain is then
used to weigh the observations and the
background forecast so this background
forecast is coming from your model the
observation is coming from the system
and the kalman gain is something that
you've computed from the background
covariance matrix
okay
now the problem with this approach is
that if you're if the system that you're
that that that your
uh
if the system that you have is very high
dimensional
then the number of ensemble members that
you need has to be sort of of the same
order of magnitude as the number of
states of your system so you really need
to integrate
all the ensemble members and if for
example this system has 36 000 states so
you really want to afford uh you really
want to be able to afford to integrate
ensemble members in in in the ranges of
2000 or 3000 which could be very
intractable for a certain system think
about the weather and climate situation
where you have 10 power eight states you
really can't afford to integrate that
many number of ensemble members using an
nwp right because that's that's too
expensive so what people typically
resort to is that okay i'll
i'll integrate a few ensemble members
typically in the order of magnitude of
and i'll resort to a low i rank a
deficient p matrix because then this
background covariance matrix becomes
rank deficient it suffers from sampling
error so it gives some spurious
correlations which
may affect the accuracy of your kelvin
gain and hence the accuracy of your
estimated state so let's look at how
this works out with different number of
ensemble members so you have 20 ensemble
members you see the normalized rmac it
tries to come down every time you have
data simulation every time you have an
observation you're assimilating you're
getting a better estimate of the state
but the overall trend of this rms curve
is upward which means this filter is not
converging it's actually divergent and
the reason is you don't have enough
number of members even with the 100
ensemble members which is sort of
interactive in the system
uh you you still have a divergent filter
only when you can increase the number of
ensembles to say 5 000
that is when you have a convergent
filter that is that that that that is
the error comes down every time you have
data simulation and you have a constant
error curve so this is really what you'd
expect
and the reason this happens is because
if you investigate the background
covariance matrix what i'm showing you
here is the correlation
that i get from p by looking at this
point on the domain
so
what i ideally expect is that this point
is correlated with itself and not
correlated with any other point in the
domain but you see there is a lot of
spurious correlations all over it should
look like this a blob of correlation at
the center and and nothing around
but it has a lot of spurious
correlations really saying that the
instantaneous wind in you know
texas is correlated to the instantaneous
wound in beijing something like that
which which which may not be true in
most cases is not true so so this is the
reason that this is this this is due to
rank deficiency this is due to sampling
error and this causes this blow up
now
what we are proposing is a deep learning
based uh circuit to enhance the
computation of p so let's see how that
how that would look like
so the first step to that process is
actually building a data-driven
surrogate for this system so instead
of integrating uh instead of instead of
integrating the system numerically one
could of course build a data-driven
emulator that
that integrates the state of the system
from time t to t plus 40 n to t
so
this emulator may not be very accurate
for very long right but we don't need it
to be accurate for a very long time we
need to be accurate for a very short
number of time steps and we have reasons
to believe as i'll show you later on
that even for very complicated systems
this approach to building fully
generated surrogates for forecasting
actually works out
and suppose that you have been able to
train it this way and you have a
surrogate that goes from time t to t
plus 40 delta t with the deep learning
model
then our approach to doing hybrid
ensemble kelvin filter is that you keep
this pathway the same
but you integrate
uh up but but you introduce a parallel
unit that integrates a large number of
ensembles from the same initial
condition now because a trained unit is
going to be very cheap during inference
you can actually afford thousands of
ensembles here and just to give you a
cost comparison of how this scales the
time required to integrate one numerical
ensemble with this numerical model is
the same as the time required to
integrate 200 of these data driven
ensembles
okay
so you keep integrating them up to 200
delta t until you get a stated 200 delta
t with the unit
and then
instead of computing the background
covariance with the with the numerical
ensembles you compute the background
covariance with these thousands and
thousands of data driven ensembles that
you were able to afford
and here's a trick that you just need
this data-driven model to be accurate
for 200 delta t it just needs to be able
to integrate accurately for 200 delta t
so you get a not rank deficient matrix p
well it is going to be random division
still but it's less
it's less than
you could have a thousands of ensembles
so it does less sampling here as
compared to numerical ensemble
so you get your back so you get your
kelvin gain based on that but your
background forecast you still get it
from a more accurate
numerical model that has integrated a
small number of ensembles something that
is affordable
so you have this hybrid approach to
computing k with the deep learning model
and the background forecast with with
the numerical model and then you get an
estimated state
uh you have their analysis state which
you hope is a better representation of
the true state of your system so let's
see how it really does
so this is a regular ensemble kelvin
filter over 60 day cycles for this
system
and it uses 20 numerical ensembles
something that is roughly tractable for
this system
now if i if i if i trade away 10 of
these numerical ensembles for 2 000 data
driven ensembles remember the cost
conversion 10 of these is equivalent to
2000 of these
the line that i get is the black line
which is stable and accurate about four
times reduction in error at the end of
60 day cycles and in fact with half the
number of
uh half the computational cost half the
number of driven ensembles
i can get the blue curve which looks
visually to have the same
accuracy
as 2000 data driven ensemble so really
this box and this box has no difference
in computation because i just traded
away 10 of these numerical ensembles for
2000 data reverence numbers
and this is the performance gain that i
have
so this model has absolutely no
forecasting skill to be honest with 20
numerical ensembles while this model
would have a far better forecasting
skill and the reason is again the
background covariance the the spurious
sampling uh the spurious correlations
arise due to sampling error because you
have lower number of ensembles
this is what it would look like with 20
numerical ensembles trade 10 of them for
data driven ones and you would have a
much more localized structure of your
co-variance matrix
and and this gives you a better estimate
of your analysis state so if you plug
that analysis state in to your dynamical
model this is the forecast accuracies
that you would guess this is free
forecasting so this is with the analysis
state that you obtained with
with this enkf model h and kf model
so uh if you consider 0.6 to be like the
prediction horizon limit for example
then uh this model has about five and a
half days of forecast forecasting skill
while
while this model actually has much
lesser so despite the fact that their
analysis states look visually same it's
a very chaotic system so error is going
to grow very quickly so there is a
difference uh there is a advantage using
more number of data driven ensembles
now
the main challenge in this pro in this
work was never about the onslaught like
it wasn't about implementation or
enthusiasts about building that data
driven surrogate that works
and and i did it for a qg flow one could
ask what would happen when it's a more
complex system well we did it for
complex systems as well here's an
example uh
this paper and more recent papers
actually tried to build these surrogates
for
uh trained on re-analysis data so really
observational data for for for weather
and what they showed was that these
their driven models may not uh be
competitive with operational forecasting
models so ifs 363 while it's not
operational forecasting it could be
it is a nwp that is run by ecmwf which
is very accurate which is this line what
you're looking at is the acc of z 500
which is the large scale circulation
five kilometers above the earth's
surface and how the accuracy acc is like
correlation correlation coefficient and
and and this blue line is a a deep
learning based unit model that
integrates z 500 exactly the same way i
did it for qg almost exactly the same
way i did for qg
now while it is not comparable to other
operational models but for one day
it is actually quite competitive so for
if you look at a one day forecasting
skill then it is going to be competitive
to any operational model and and things
have moved on since since this picture
we have better models now but um for one
day it can be very competitive and
that's what we need for for data
simulation we don't need it to be
accurate forever we just need to be
accurate for the length of time until
which i get another observation and i
can integrate it and we also showed that
you can improve more uh improve on these
models by adding more physics into it
and talk about this this picture on the
right uh in in a short bit but it is
possible to build these data different
circuits for short time scales which can
be in fact as accurate today it can be
as accurate as operational ifs models
that ecmw influence
now of course this is the challenge that
we talked about let's go to a more
complex system like i said what is what
would be what is the main challenge of
having a more complex system uh well one
of them is we have we are sort of uh
married to a convolutional architecture
which in the unit was a convolutional
architecture one of the things we wanted
to ask was
was it even uh did it make sense to have
a convolutional architecture in the
first place and and one of the things
that we did earlier on with an extreme
events paper was that you realize that
you know us if you look at the weather
patterns on on on
if you look at the z500 circulation
patterns you may have for example a high
pressure anomaly over a low pressure
anomaly or you may have a situation
where you have a low pressure anomaly
over high pressure now these two are
different uh configurations of the
pressure system right
and and these two really would be
treated as should be treated as two
different features now i think it's
important here because this can likely
lead to an extreme event
while this would probably just be a
rosby way of moving eastward
so these two are different situations
and it turns out that your your
convolutional architecture which is
invariant to translation but not
rotation and other orientations can't
really uh by construction figure out uh
the difference between these two
if this is extracted as a feature set
then these two are the same features
because it does not understand the
relative differences between
orientations
not to say that it never would if you
traded enough number of samples these
are very expressive networks it might
but they're not that by construction
right they're not equivalent by
construction and and there's a better
architecture to go about in doing that
and a very long time back this was
called capsule neural networks and now
we have better versions of equivalent
neural networks that deal with this but
generally the idea is that you have to
be able to capture rotational rotational
variances in your features the
rotational variance in the in the flow
features when you're when you're when
you're trying to predict especially for
physical systems such as these right
uh so so capturing rotational features
became an important challenge especially
for complex systems and and
and really what we wanted to do was if
you're if if your input for example your
your state was rotating in this manner i
wanted i want my neural network and i'm
calling it a stationary transformer in
this case to be able to really capture
the rotational behavior like really
capture the features that are that are
rotating in space at least the so3 part
we want our networks to be uh so3 eq
variant that's that that's one of the
things that that we realized we needed
to do
and the reason is that the current
convolutional architectures are cooling
less and in most cases and pooling
layers are effective for training the
system it has that you know it provides
inductive bias that you need to train
these models but then it what what
happens is that you know you can't
capture features
um
especially when there are large
distortions in the input space
and and and to capture rotational
features uh is very important for for
spatial temporal modeling because you
know we know that turbulent flow has
wattages that are moving around in space
so we wanted to be able to incorporate a
differentiable model so that we can do
end-to-end back propagation but at the
same time be able to make at least some
portions of the network equivalent to
rotations
so if this is a unit our simple solution
to having
some
sense of equivalence within this network
this is not a fully equivalent network
is to really have a spatial transformer
in the living space so you ensure that
your latest space undergoes a
transformation and undergoes you know uh
unfine transformations
define transformation
and then you interpolate it based on
your based on on on on on the input to
the network right so this is called a
spatial transformer network and i what i
really did was i took a special
transformer network and and hooked it to
the latest space of unit so i'm not
making the entire network endpoint
equivalent i'm just ensuring that this
this transformation is equivalent by
construction so that when i go to the
decoder i have a representation which
captures the richness of the rotational
features of my field
so
uh so we so
exactly the same way that we that we did
for the qg flow we started training this
on observation later we analysis data
with an usda network this kind of a
network again zt zt plus delta t
here we have uh we have trained this
model on 12 hourly z500 data
and and and and this is what
this is what this is what we get out of
our
free forecast for a free forecast so we
have about four five like maybe five
days of accuracies for z 500 from error
five reanalysis and we realize that an
equivalence preserving network in the
it's not equivalent end to end it's only
in the latent space but nikoi's
preserving network has has better
correlation as compared to say
a regular unit not so much in the
earlier days maybe a little more as you
move forward in time and it can capture
like subtle features like like wave
breaking
like you see the wave breaking phenomena
happening in high latitudes which is
being captured by the equivalence
preserving network
and we don't necessarily say that we
better represent these phenomena these
are very non-linear phenomena but maybe
we better capture features that
ultimately leads to a better
representation at this point so that's
this is what we realized and this was
just just a better network 12 year
stands for the fact that we are
training this on 12 hourly data instead
of hourly data and there's a carry the
reason why i'm doing 12 hourly or not
hourly and i'll tell you about it
so this is what the acc would look like
it has about one and a half days uh
better accuracy it's a marginal
improvement but you know we get we will
take what we can get for these systems
so it's about
if you cut things off at 0.6 it has
about one and a half days of better
accuracy to a regular uh very over
parameterized network both of them these
have undergone extensive hpo before we
decide to use this network
now
now adding data simulation to this is
obviously more complicated because if
you want to do forecasting on area 5 you
need to be able to run an nwp model
which is sort of not our forte but
instead what you can think of is that
you treat this ustn you treat this
data-driven circuit as your dynamic
number as your background forecast model
so replace the dynamical model
altogether so you start with an initial
condition on z you use your ustn right
to predict z t plus delta t t plus two
delta t until for about 24 hours when
you have an observation
and then you directly integrate this
observation into your data driven
dynamical model to say
and here instead of using ensembl kelvin
filter we use an uncentered version of
it uh because we were using the low
resolution error 5 we could actually
afford an optimal number of ensemble
members the thing is this system is
about 2048 dimensional right this is the
low resolution five and a half degree
error five
and and for the unscented kelvin filter
the the optimal number of ensembles that
you need is about two times the
dimension of your system plus one so we
could really afford 4000 ensembles
because our forecasting model was a
fully data-driven model which was
trained previously
so
uh the the formulation for us for also
for unscented kalman filter is very
similar you compute a kelvin gain uh
based on the kelvin gain you get an
analysis state at 24 delta t and if you
look at the results once again this is
the correlation this is rmse every time
you have data assimilation you see that
your error goes down i have
these experiments
have
the two experiments here one with a
higher higher degree of noise one with a
lower degree of noise obviously the
amount of noise you have in your
observation governs the amount of
accuracy of that you have your analysis
state but anything around and this is in
meters this rms is in meters for z 500
and this is correlation coefficient so
you see you can get very decent
correlation coefficient even with high
degree of noise for this system
now uh once we did that we realized
there's something more interesting here
and the interesting thing is that these
data-driven models don't the error
propagation in these data-driven models
don't quite behave the same way as the
error propagation in numerical models uh
by saying that what i mean is that if
you train a model to predict 12 hourly
data 12 hourly states
you would likely to have a longer
prediction horizon
as compared to a model that is trained
on hourly hourly date or hourly state so
if your model is going from x t to x t
plus one hour
you're going to lose prediction more
quickly than a model that's going from x
t to x t plus 10 ounce
and this could be useful uh uh i don't
want i don't want to take a lot of time
talking about why this happens although
we have some ideas and now we have
more uh explainable experiments to show
what happens but we can leverage this
thing so basically what i'm trying to
say here is that ustn 12 which is
trained on 12 hourly data has a better
prediction on the horizon as compared to
a ust and one which is trained on hourly
data similarly for rmsc
so a 12 hourly model is more accurate
than an hourly model
so what we can do now is use both these
models together in our data simulation
scheme and we call this uh virtual
observations that is if you you really
want to do prediction every hour but you
know your hourly model is bad and your
12 hourly model is much better so let's
use both these models in conjunction so
you have an hourly model doing
prediction every hour until say for
example 12 hours
what you do is you take the state
predicted by the 12 hourly model and
treat it as a virtual observation
and integrate it to get an analysis
state so this is not a real observation
you don't have an observation from the
system what you have is a more accurate
forecast let's treat it as a virtual
observation and get a better estimate at
this 12th hour so that you can start
forecasting with a better initial
condition at the 12th hour
and you keep doing that until you go to
24 hours you get the real observation
so
when you do that you see that the blue
line is essentially the the this vibe
with the virtual observation framework
which we call the multi-step
framework in this case
and what you see that every 12 hours you
have a peak in your in your correlation
or you have a drop in your rmc which
means that the virtual observations are
really kicking in and helping you get an
improved state as compared to the
regular ml plus da and this happens
throughout and you have a divergent free
filter at all times because you could
afford 4000 ensemble members so this is
really our approach to doing multi-time
step da with with multiple models and it
really works with data data models
even for for for data as complex as
observational weather data
so with this i'll i'll come to my
conclusions as you know so that we can
have some time for questions i'm
[Music]
10 minutes above 30 minutes or 10
minutes beyond 12 30. so um
so one of the challenges always the
challenge in these problems is building
a skillful ddwp model a data driven
weather prediction model that is that is
uh that is you know competitive with
operational models right but we're not
far behind there are there are papers
coming out more and more that are
showing that we can really achieve this
and while most of them were on low
resolution uh fields
uh we along with a few folks at working
lab and nvidia have been working on this
really monster of an afno model with 33
atmospheric variables at the native era
5 resolutions the highest resolution
error 5 and and these results are
comparable to operational uh operational
ifs which is ecmws operational model
so
uh
it so it's really going somewhere so
really replay so when like six years
back if people talked about replace a
dynamical core with a data driven model
no one would believe you but six that
since then there's been a lot of
progress and maybe we couldn't think
about at least replacing some components
so for example you can do all the
atmospheric variables maybe but this is
the first time we did about 33
atmospheric variables and this preprint
will be coming out very soon
uh there can be further improvement by
having physics-based biases into the
architecture for example equivalence was
one of them you could do other things
like enforcing the loss function with
some physical quantities all of this is
harder to do for real systems like real
observational data but but that one can
one can think about doing this even if
you have a great data driven model
getting initial conditions in real time
is a challenge like if you really
if you really want to
start forecasting in real time you you
want initial conditions coming in from a
weather station at the same time as you
want forecast this is obviously an iot
sort of challenge there which which
needs to be
taken care of you have to look at
further explorations in doing da because
data simulation is always a challenge
you need to be able to integrate your
observations and noises parts you can
never really use them you have to be
able to assimilate them so further
improvements and data simulation with
deep learning needs to be uh performed
and finally the holy grail in using
data-driven models is that can be
seamlessly integrate this data-driven
weather prediction models
uh to get climatology
and at least today we can't do that
because these models are unstable and
they drift
not that nwp models don't even whether
models will drip they don't give you
climate that's why there's weather
models are not climate models but really
one of the holy grails was that we could
really do that that you can integrate
these data driven weather prediction
models because they don't have the same
biases as as
as
numerical weather models maybe you would
be able to integrate them currently this
is
things that we and other people are
working on but there's a lot of evidence
that there is unphysical drifts and
instability
so this is more or less the challenges
less conclusions more challenges uh and
with that i'm open to questions
thank you thank you so much for the
great talk ashish
we do have a you know tons of tons of
questions from pat actually
i
actually i i don't even know where to
start that um
youngster we don't have to go over these
i can always take them offline with with
the speaker i i i've really learned a
lot from this talk okay but there are a
bunch of assumptions you make along the
way
that uh
to someone like me who comes from a very
different background i'm going well why
why are you willing to assume that or
this or this and so i know that for the
the computational science audience
the who do who do these kinds of models
many of these assumptions will be
familiar
i think they are debatable and worth
worth exploring but uh but i think the
biggest surprise for me
it wasn't that you were
starting from
from these fine-grained pde models right
that's a pretty common thing uh what's
really surprised me was a shift to and i
knew that ensembles are you used in in
weather weather prediction these days um
i was
uh but
but but
i've i've never understood the
connection there because if you believe
that navier stokes equations or whatever
are enough
and they're correct um then why in the
world do you need ensembles and and and
if you believe that the world is markov
why do you need column and filtering
these these are there's there's a
there's a disconnect
between
the
between the uh the the basic assumptions
of of
pde modeling and and the way that that
people have gone ahead with with
actually incorporating these ideas from
statistics
it's not evil but it's it seems to me
violating core assumptions of what it
means to build a scientific model what's
going on there can you help me
understand the motivation or is it just
a hack
um yeah i can i can uh
give you a shot um
so why do we need ensembles if if navier
stokes is accurate right
so
one is
even though so so we're not analytically
solving knowledge we're approximating
navistox with a numerical solver so
there are two sources of error here
one
is a model error so so the navier stoke
solver in this case the qg solver
although it's as accurate as a solver as
i could write it would have some finite
sized approximation so there's a model
error here which is very small because
this is a it's a spectral solver it's
actually very small you can neglect it
for this for the timing
but the other source of error here which
is a major solution
wait but won't those average out or is
there something about the chaotic nature
of it that that
that does not let averaging
get rid of of uh the errors
okay so if you even if you neglect model
error the initial condition error will
not average out because it's a chaotic
system it's a positive lyapunov exponent
the initial condition error with which
you are say you have a perfect
but an imperfect initial condition so
you will never actually be able to
retrain the trajectory of your truth and
it will not average out because it's a
it has a positive level of exponent and
the error would grow now what ensembling
here does is that so so if you have an
initial condition error one way to go
around it is on sampling
now
what ensemble kelvin filter is doing is
it's slightly different what it's doing
is that it is weighing in between this
ensemble model forecast
and
again a piece of imperfect information
that is coming from the observation now
this model forecast could have had a lot
many errors he could have had model
errors this model may not have been
perfect in this system i've i've written
a qg solver in an nwp in a weather
forecasting model there is missing
physics so so obviously your model
forecast is going to deviate a lot even
if you had a perfect initial condition
for example but your observation is
coming from the true system it has all
the physics but it has other challenges
it's noisy it's it's parts as soon as it
spars and you want to put it on inside a
dynamical model you need to interpolate
onto the right grid so there you have a
process so what what ensemble kermit
filter is doing is that in this equation
as you see it's weighing in
between
the observation
and the background
forecast with this kalman gain and this
carbon gain is sort of like you know if
it was one dimensional it would be like
a weight whether should i should i trust
my observations more should i trust my
model for customer and
that trust is coming by looking at the
the how the background covariance looks
like if the background covariance looks
good based on that you decide on what
what the key is that's okay so so i this
is i mean as i expected this is a
complicated answer to a complicated
problem and that's all right um
i don't even know how you would you know
to uh to me maybe everyone else on the
on the
listening in the talk already got this
right but i certainly didn't and so i
would encourage you to to spend a couple
of slides clarifying where this is
coming from in particular yeah where are
the sources of error and how is how is
the common filter and the ensemble how
are they addressing those different
sources of error um and i and and and so
i i like i like the style of your answer
i'd like to understand more maybe
can introduce us by email and we can
follow up separately
and i'll be questioning with other
people to talk
i can certainly do that
thank you thank you so much for the
question pat um and answering um
all right
well the robot said he had the same
question and he's thanking
you
all right um so i'm i don't know if if
there's any other questions please um
please post it in the chat room or admit
yourself um
while you're doing that let me ask my
question
on this very slide and you're
computing the covariance um
using the unit
yes and that
and the units
you set um
you know
it is accurate for
like the first day
up to say for example
up to 24 hours or one day or um
and in order to achieve that accuracy um
i was i was wondering if you can
you know elaborate on how you train the
unit actually um sure sure
so
this in this particular example this
this is a very regular unit i don't have
any physics constraints equivalent stuff
here so the way it has been trained is
that i've generally so i have a
simulation data a long
long climate simulation from this qg
flow
and this the input to this unit is the
stream function at both levels at time t
and the output is the stream function at
both levels at time t plus 40 delta t
here 40 degrees that vection time scale
of this system
so i have trained this unit exactly in
this fashion i've shown it multiple
samples of t and t plus 40 delta t and
i've learned a map between t to t plus
40 delta t during inference
it's an auto regressive model you put in
an initial condition t you get t plus 40
delta t you take this prediction plug it
back into the unit you get t plus 80
delta t you plug it back you get t plus
160 delta t and so on
and and that's uh um
in small scale data or the large-scale
data um the data you use to train the
unit uh this is this is so uh in this
problem it's trained on the full high
resolution full resolution data there's
no there's a large scale defined
resolution yeah
okay and as you increase the size of
that
data
you will have a hard time training the
unit itself
so we used about
10 000 data for example in this case uh
so
you mean in terms of computational cost
that that yeah yeah yeah
yeah this is an expensive training
process to be honest uh i mean this is
this is this 36 thousand dimensional so
it's an expensive training process but
during influence it can be you know as
cheap as it gets so yeah it's training
10 000 days uh yeah i don't doubt the
inference will be very fast and once it
is trained to be very um you know
you know accurately and
with enough data
the training is always the challenging
part
the trend is pretty costly
right and
in for example in global climate model
the the size of the data will be even
even bigger
yeah
so and it would have much more number of
variables but yeah so it's so like that
uh the fno model that we have been doing
with nvidia it has 33 atmospheric
variables at quarter degree resolution
so it's a mammoth model you have to do
distributed you know model parallelism
to to really train it but
but then you know once trained you can
actually deploy it in on one gpu so
that's that's that's something yeah yeah
once it is trained yes uh yeah of course
um
okay we have a
question from dave at the end uh you
showed how one could
combine the one hour unit and a 12 hour
unit yeah and compare it to the one hour
unit alone
how does the solution compare to using
only the 12-hour unit
okay what is the advantage of the hourly
calculation
correct great so uh i'm not showing you
the uh the the the comparison with 12
hourly unit is because like okay so the
assumption is um
you want predictions every hour
so it's it's not that
if i used a 24-hour unit i would have
probably got gotten away with better
accuracy but the point is if you use
that then you don't get any prediction
between 0 and 24 hours or if you just
the 12 hour unit you won't get
predictions between 0 and 12 hours so
you do one prediction every hour so
that's that's the requirement but how
can you use hierarchically low fidelity
models to improve that hourly that
forecast because until here there is no
improvement
but once you have the virtual
observation you have an updated state so
every hour from there
would now have a better
better accuracy as compared to just
using the hourly unit right
so so basically until here there was
hardly any change but after that
you you you had an improvement in the
state so
because these different fidelity models
have different accuracies
i want to improve that
ultimately i need hourly forecasts so i
have to improve like i can't just say
i'll not use the r i have to use the
hourly model but how can i reinforce
hourly model by using these virtual
observations so that that was the idea
that's why i didn't compare with the
12-volume
sounds good thank you
um
baby said thanks i didn't catch the one
hour forecast requirements
all right uh any other question from
audience um
this is ramit i have a quick question
for you hi thanks thanks for the talk
yeah uh
so so it was regarding the the virtual
observation concept so
could you like just build it into the
architecture with a resnet layer that
does d a like a d a layer or something i
don't know
so that you have data assimilation
happening through a parallel sort of
operation at each time step perhaps
and you just choose the window of the
output the total window of the output
which could be like 12 in this case for
example
does that make sense no
yeah
it did make sense i mean
we have to we have to like talk about it
and figure but what what you just said
strikes right you're right
okay yeah another question is so you
know like a lot of the papers that are
being published recently these are all
on the 64 by 32 resolution with the exam
with the exception of the work you're
doing with nvidia
so is there any value to those forecasts
i'm not talking about whether they work
i'm just curious if anybody uses a 64 by
32 forecast
not if it's at very large so we are
looking at z 500 data that's why okay 60
32 is okay but the one jaideep is
leading at nvidia that was at quarter
degree so the other thing is training on
many variables so if you don't
reduce the number of i don't reduce the
resolution native resolution
then training this model becomes very
hard for a large number of atmospheric
variables that's why i also looked at
like things like just z500 t2m t850 very
large-scale slow moving variables right
precipitation this is totally useless
useless yeah
okay all right okay thank you so much
[Music]
uh going back to the the the ram is the
first uh the comments about the parallel
implementation
i don't know it reminds me of the
the parallel in time uh algorithm
yeah
so if you if you introduce the
you know artificial uh the observations
and yes
that it
that framework is totally possible to
apply right yeah not take off the
integer
that's that's right as soon as room
mentioned it i i realized that yeah it
could it yeah it's very possible it's
probably very possible yeah
all right okay so
another question from shady the very
nice talk ashish i might have missed
that point but when you introduce a
rotational invariant neural network with
a
spatial transformer it would see a low
pressure john
on top of a high pressure zone
as the same as a high pressure joint on
top of a low pressure zone right
how is this physically consistent
yeah so uh okay let me clarify so know
that
first of all this was just a cartoon uh
but but that's not what i was what i
meant was that
um if you have uh
so so so con convolutional neural
networks especially with pooling
uh is is not rotationally equivalent
which means that it cannot it cannot
capture
rotational distortion generally any
large scale distortion is in the input
field so it can't capture rotational
distortion input not by construction if
that doesn't mean that it can't that
doesn't mean if you rotate a cat it
won't be able to predict it if it's
trained on you know all the images of
cats so that's that's not why we have it
but construction it is not rotationally
equivalent right transl it has
translation variance it does it cannot
capture rotational variances in the
future field
so this was one and not just rotation
any relative orientations so i think you
can actually find a very good uh
uh overview of exactly how that works
and so so in this painting for example
uh this this would be for example
classified by a continent to be a face
where in reality it's not really a phase
because the relative positions of of of
of the eyes and the and the lips that
sort of change so changes in relative
positions can be captured by
construction once again i use the word
construction because
if you train on enough data data
augmentation these things can do
anything so
when we're doing this work on extreme
events we realize this is one of the
problems we were having that
these two
large if these two are captured as large
features
in in in one of the layers in a
convenient they would they they both of
them were captured as the same feature
basically both of them were leading to
the same prediction
but they they might not they may they
should not right because this might
cause something this will definitely not
cause something
so and we realized the issue was with
the fact that it was not rotationally
equivalent and at that time we solved it
by doing capsules because
but then we realized capsules has you
know other implementation challenges
especially with scaling and stuff
so we went ahead with spatial
transformers again special from what
facial transformers would do is that it
would ensure that i am capturing the
rotation or any destroy any sort of yeah
rotation scaling and you know
translation so anything in the in in our
theta matrix it would capture uh
uh from input from input to output here
of course we can't afford uh
an end to end spatial transformer so we
just put it on the latent space again
does that make sense
all right i hope that answers the shade
is questioned and
is it sufficient shady
i assume it is
all right uh is there any questions okay
he said make sense yes okay great
wonderful is there any questions from
audience
oh yeah i have a quick question yeah
very nice talk uh yeah i'm actually
working on totally different kind of
domain like substrates problem but doing
it very similar kind of framework we are
using some data simulation as well and
then
when you do some construction of
this data model and is there any way to
incorporate certain kind of physical
constraint rather than just data driven
only so that you may be able to
kind of
preserve certain properties like some
invariants i think your transformer
kind of
algorithm made good but i think when i
look at some other kind of turbulence
kind of community or fluid dynamics they
really try to preserve certain
properties either from tensor
or some other physics right and and
since i i'm quite curious about this
kind of weather forecasting as well so
you may have certain quantity you really
want to preserve during data 31
consumption
yeah
yeah so there's been a there's been
actually a lot of work around that now
uh so if you were doing a more canonical
fluid dynamic assistance you could think
about putting conservation laws right
now you can do it in two ways you can do
it in the loss function so you have a
penalty term with the conservation law
which is a soft constraint which means
that it will not be exactly satisfied or
we could come up with a clever way to
change to write a custom layer that
incorporates the conservation right if
you are doing for example divergent free
condition then you could you know
predict on the curve of your output so
that it would and then have a custom
layer with with your divergence so that
it becomes by default divergence free
and things like that
but obviously for weather and climate
it's it's much more difficult to think
about these things
but
uh i would
but there have been work around it so
for example for generalizing neural
networks across climate change scenarios
there has been some work done by tom
weichler in terms of um
um
scaling like using the classes club
relationship to scale the input so that
it generalizes that's one thing
and then again the same guy tom uh
probably tom beckler has and definitely
my creatures would they have a paper in
prl where they talk about putting any
kind of heart constraint into neural
architectures and then they show an
example with
either a convection or some
thermodynamic quantity in an actual
atmospheric model but that paper is
about putting hard constraints in
architecture analytical heart
concentration architecture and any
general heart constraints uh it's a
paper in prl that came out maybe a year
ago that really talks about how it will
but
yeah it is definitely possible and there
have been different different work
around it but it's obviously much more
difficult for weather and climate as
compared to canonical like fluid
dynamical systems
it's much more
tractable
yep i mean if time allowed i have one
more following
yeah you touch based on very important
aspect of this weather forecasting
because your weather gets nearly
influenced by your initial condition
dramatically weather changes quite a bit
and
like for data driven forecasting how low
blows that to your data-driven focused
model really account for those change of
initial condition otherwise you have to
retrain your mother with different
initial conditions every time right okay
wonderful so
yeah that's a great great question
so
you're obviously talking about a change
in initial condition that is coming in
due to a distributional shift in your
system right for example climate change
has happened so you're in so that that
kind of changes initial condition that
you're talking about right where you
have to retrain your model entirely
so
yes
um under a situation where there's
distributional shift that means for this
climate change system has changed
reynolds number has changed something
has changed these models will not
generalize that's that's the like that's
that's the final answer there's no way
this generalizes so
we have worked on this extensively one
of the things we can do is transfer
learning of course transfer learning is
again a whole new different ball game
which layers do you retain how much data
that you do you need
so we have a very nice explainability
framework around it the way to go about
generalizing these neural networks is to
do transfer learning unless you come up
with a very clever relationship so that
if you like for example tom wycler's
paper it looked at variables which you
know were affected by temperature and
you used it as a scleroderma scale in a
very clever paper but it was and and and
it really looked at generalization but
if you don't have the
uh you don't have the luxury if you
don't have that kind of relationship for
certain systems then the only way to go
about it is doing transfer learning and
then you have to understand which layers
to retrain
how how what are the physics that is
getting transferred how we can really
optimize which layers you can retrain so
we have this framework where you can
look at the change in your system and
then determine which layers to retrain
by looking at lost surfaces and things
like that and this was heavily motivated
by stuff that michael mahoney does
i know he gave a talk a couple of maybe
weeks back so yeah the way to go about
is transfer learning and there may be
ways to improve how to effectively do
transfer learning maybe even in online
mode if you don't have
uh capabilities the way tom bradley did
in that paper uh yeah
yeah yeah thanks for yeah detailed yeah
explanation i mean that's kind of what
we are kind of thinking about but you
know i think
by uh based on my experience actually
some kind of challenge we face through
the actual data
or kind of problem itself really give us
some chance to think about more kind of
a small way yep thanks yeah thanks for
response
thank you thank you so much for the good
question and
um the nice answer
by ashish
is there any other questions
okay if not let's thank our speaker
ashish and i um
thank you so much for the great talk and
um a wonderful q a sessions um
um
i just you're hiding yourself
let me i'll
stop sharing
oh all right oh okay yeah that's fine
yeah thank you so much for um
for hosting me thanks a lot i hope to
keep yeah
that would be wonderful all right um
thank you everyone uh we will i think we
have another gdpr seminar next week so i
will announce that uh as as soon as i
get
uh all the the information from the
speakers all right until then
have a nice weekend and week everyone
and i will see you next week
all right let me